Herkese
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
merhaba hepiniz hoşgeldiniz
bugün sizlere değişen dünyanın insanı ve
çalışma hayatını nasıl etkilediğine dair
konuşmak istiyorum
bildiğiniz gibi iş yaşamında Çok şey
değişti ve değişmeye de devam ediyor
Bunun sadece 30 yıl önce ofislerimizde
bilgisayar dahi yokken email nedir
bilmezken bugün yapay dar zekâdan
bahsediyor ve yapay süper zeka
dönemlerine nasıl hazırlana bileceğim
izi düşünüyoruz
bu işte böyle bir dönem içerisinde de
İnsanın neden ve nasıl değiştiğini
anlamaya ihtiyaç duyuyoruz
Ben
konuşmama varoluştur psikoterapinin
kurucularından Avusturyalı Victor
Franklin bir sözüyle Başlamak isterim
frenkel der ki eğer herkes mükemmel
olsaydı o zaman Her birimizin yeri bir
başkası tarafından rahatlıkla
doldurulabilir Didi Evet mükemmel
değiliz ve işin ilginç tarafı mükemmel
olmadığımızın da farkındayız mükemmel
olmadığımız gibi birbirimizin aynısı da
değiliz kişilik lerimiz farklı
karakterlerimiz farklı ilgi alanlarımız
farklı bir fakat buna rağmen
hepimizin içinde bir mükemmeli arayış
var peki bu ihtiyaç nereden geliyor diye
baktığımızda
bunun da cevabını felsefede buluyoruz
Aristoteles belki teknik doğanın
şu anda eksik bıraktığını tamamlama
çabasıdır yani Boyumuzun yetişmediği
yerde merdiveni kanatlarımızın olmadığı
ve uçma mız gereken yerde uçağı icat
ettik ve icat etmeye de devam edeceğiz
Öyleyse insanı
düşüncelerini davranışlarını
arayışlarını değiştiren
makros faktörler nelerdir Gelin bugün
biraz Bunlara bakalım
Bunlardan birincisi kentleşme ve 2030
yılına geldiğimizde Dünya nüfusunun
yüzde ellisi şehirlerde yaşıyor olacak
Türkiye'de 1950 yılında nüfus 21
milyondu bu nüfusun yüzde 24'ü
şehirlerde yaşıyordu bugün 84 milyonun
yüzde 84 bu şehirlerde yaşıyor
batının 3 yüzyıla yaydığı bu kentleşmeyi
Türkiye son 50 yıla sıkıştırdı Peki bu
hareketlilik ne anlama geliyor
kırlardan kentlere geçişlerde Sanayi
toplumuna geçiş vardı Sanayi toplumunda
mekâna bağlılık ve hiyerarşik bir düzen
söz konusuydu oysa bugün kentleşmenin
yanı sıra Metropol yaşamlardan da
bahsediyoruz bu metropollerde Bilgi
toplumu yaşarıyor bilgi toplumunda
zamandan ve Mekandan bağımsızlık söz
konusu
karardan kentlere geçtiğimizde insan
doğal hayatından Mekanik bir yaşama
geçti 95 çalıştığımız karmaşık ruhsuz
sıkıcı bir hayat
kentlerden metropollere geçtiği ya neyse
24 saat çalıştığımız sürekli bilgi
bombardımanına maruz kaldığımız iş
güvenliği mizin olmadığı kaygılı ve ve
riskli bir yaşam
ve klordan kentlere geçişlerde olduğu
gibi kentlerden metropollere geçişlerde
de tüm gündelik pratik lerimiz
değerlerimiz ilişkilerimiz anlayış
larımız değişti Bu nasıl mı mı Örneğin
bir dönem orta sınıflar iyi gelir elde
ediyordu bu orta sınıflar aynı oldukları
Mahalle kültürlerinden çıkıp güvenlikli
olduğunu düşündükleri rezidanslara geçiş
yaptılar
buralarda kendi kültürlerini ve izole
dünyalarını yarattılar
ve
böylece şehrin içerisinde küçük şehir
cikler oluşmaya başladı ama bu
rezidanslarda Mahalle hayatını
bulamadılar buralarda Kimse kimseyi
tanımıyordu kimsenin kimseye vakti yoktu
komşuluk sınırlıydı ve bireysellik
yaşanıyordu fakat yine de insanlar bu
rezistanslı ki hayatlarını önemse diler
Çünkü bir de şehrin içerisinde
kendi küçük dünyalarını kurmaya ihtiyaç
duydular
ki bu süreç
sınıfları da zorunlu bir Get dolaşmaya
iterek şehrin uçlarına gönderdi Böylece
sınıflar arası kutuplar artmaya başladı
birlik ve beraberlik azaldı ay diye
duygusu yok oldu her sınıf kendi
bölgesinde zamanı harcayınca ortak bir
şehir duygusu da yok oldu
işte bu rezidanstaki insanın
yalnızlığıyla git dolardaki dışlanmışlık
ın
dışlanmış insanların yalnızlığı bir
ortak Yalnızlığa işaret ediyor
insanı değiştiren bir diğer faktör s
aile yapısı Eskiden geniş aileler vardı
anne baba anneanneler dedeler
babaanneler herkes birlikte yaşardı
birbirlerinden
o günleri de o şimdi çekirdek aileyi
katmanları ayırarak tanımlıyoruz
çekirdek aileyi şöyle tanımlıyoruz tek
kişilik çekirdek aile sadece eşlerden
oluşan çekirdek aile eşler ve
çocuklardan oluşan çekirdek aile pike
bebeğin ve çocuklardan oluşan çekirdek
aile ve bir çekirdek aile ile yanında
farklı bir kişinin yaşadığı ortamlara
Biz aile diyoruz
insanı değiştiren bir diğer dinamiği Ben
solo seçimler olarak tanımlıyorum Bugün
Türkiye'de her 67 Evlen birinde yalnız
yaşam var Fransız sosyolog
Jump out kalkman 20 yüzyılda Bu aile
yaşamından yalnız yaşama doğru geçişi
bir Ace değil önlenemez Yükselişi olarak
tanımlıyor sonra seçimleri Ben dört
kategoride inceliyorum Bunlardan
birincisi sola yaşam var yani yaşam
seçimlerini sola yapmayı tercih eden
insan Örneğin son 10 yılda sola seyahat
yükselişte
2008 yılından bu yana sola seyahat eden
kadınların oranı yüzde 150 artış
ve bu insanların motivasyonlarına
baktığınızı otonomi ve bireysellik
ihtiyacının ön planda olduğunu görüyoruz
tuz insanlar artık solo yemek yemeyi
tercih ediyor
kalabalıklardan Yorulan insan inzivaya
çekilerek sola yaşamları tercih ediyor
bu bir ikincisi Soma ilişkiler dünyada
olduğu gibi Türkiye'de de evlilik
oranları düşüyor ve boşanma oranları
yükseliyor
şora ile siz yaşam aynı zamanda
sorumluluktan kaçışı da ifade ediyor
kimi Uzmanlar İnsanların bu dönemini
infantilizm yani ebedi çocukluk olarak
yorumluyor 3
Bu bir üçüncüsü sulu çocuklar
economic sebeplerden iş hayatının yoğun
olmasından ve dalmış ailelerden kaynaklı
sebepler Dolayısıyla Artık insanlar tek
çocuk tercih ediyorum Böylece küçük
yaşlardan itibaren sola yaşamaya
başlıyoruz ve bir dördüncüsü sola
yaşlılık hem Ömür uzuyor hem de bu solo
yaşamlarıyla birlikte solu Yaşlılıkta
beraberinde geliyor
ömrü uzayan insanın karşılaştığı en
büyük ızdırap yakınlarını kaybetmesi
oluyor işte Hem bu ızdırap hem de
yalnızlığın verdiği yük artınca
gözlerimizde yaşlanıyor İşte bu yüzden
hepimiz için daha iyi bir yaşlılık
dönemine hazırlanmak önemli bir hale
İşte bu yüzden
hayatı ustaca yaşama becerisi elde
etmenin yollarını arıyoruz
kentleşme aile yapısının değişmesi ve
solo seçimlerle birlikte ekonomik yapıda
İnsanı değiştiriyor bir son 10 yılda ya
Enflasyonun 5 kat artması ekonominin
önündeki en önemli sorun olarak
karşımızda duruyor Bununla birlikte Hani
halkında çalışan sayısı da artıyor
iktisatçılar bir aile içerisinde
çalışanların sayısı artarsa bu aynı
zamanda refahta bir düşüklüğe de işaret
eder diyor Bu bir grup insan bağımsız ve
özgür yaşarken diğer bir grup insan
hayatının farklı bir yükünü taşıyor ve
bu Özgür insanla arasındaki farkı
anlamlandıramıyorum
o kadının işgücüne katılımı ile Elbette
refahta da bir artış sağlandı aynı
zamanda sosyokültürel olarak ve
gelişmeye başladık kadının ekonomik
özgürlüğünü kabul kavuşması ile birlikte
sosyalleşme ihtiyacı da artık End ve
Metropol yaşamlarında insanın zamanı
kısıtlı olunca bu sosyalleşme ihtiyacı
işyerlerine yönlendirildi
annemi de önce her dört beyaz yakadan
birinin işsiz olduğundan bahsediyorduk
pandemi ile birlikte her beş gençten
birinin işsiz olduğunu konuşuyoruz
işsizlikte mi kaynaklanan bu korku
çalışma hayatımızda etkiliyor Örneğin
ekonomi ninnice beden iyi olduğu
dönemlerde bankalar kredi vermişti
ihtiyacı olanlar da al bu ama iş burada
bitmedi
ardından Depresyona girdim kredi çektim
Depresyona girdim haberlerini duymaya
başladık Yani bu sorun sadece kredi
çeken değil Ailesini de etkileri
mortgage ve kredi borcu olanların
korkusu ve endişesi iş yapış şekillerini
etkiliyor
şu kendisinden beklenen leke hissettiği
kaygı arasında kaldığında risksiz olanı
yani rutini seçiyor
ya Bodrum aynı zamanda dünyanın da en
büyük sorunu olan anksiyete ve
depresyonu beraberinde getirir bu durum
Hem çalışma hayatımızı hem çalışma
sosyal hayatımızı hem de aile
ilişkilerimizi kökten etkiliyor
şu korkusu ve endişesi yüksek olan insan
yaratıcı yenilikçi cesaretli yani
ilerlemeci kaslarını kullanmıyor
ve yenilikçilik yaratıcılık ve inovasyon
Arzu edilen ama bir türlü elde
edilemeyen olarak kalıyor insanı
değiştiren bir diğer faktör Elbette
teknoloji Ben teknoloji iki eksende
inceliyorum Bunlardan birincisi
Almanların ortaya attığı endüstri 4.0
endüstri 4.0
ekonomik fayda Modeli üzerine kurulu bir
sistem ifade ediyor bu modele göre
teknoloji
verimliliği ve kârlılığı getirmek
üzerine bulunur diğer bir eksende de
toplum 5.0 bulunuyor Japonların ortaya
attı toplum 5.0 süper yapay süper zeka
dönemlerinde insanın rolünün ne olması
gerektiği üzerinde çalışır Bu bağlamda
teknoloji Bu bir insanın yaşam
kalitesini
arttırmak üzerine yer alıyor
şu teknoloji Elbette hepimizi bireysel
leştir dibi Örneğin Eskiden müzik
dinlemek bir sosyalleşmenin Ya da
birlikte olmanın sembolü iken bukmenin
ortaya çıkmasıyla müzik
bireyselleştirme ipod'un ortaya çıkması
istediğiniz müziğe İstediğiniz zaman
kavuşabilmek imkanı verdi Böylece arzu
ediyor ve istiyorsam hak ediyorum dur
anlayışı oturmaya başladı akıllı
telefonların ortaya çıkmasıyla bilgi
daha kolay ulaşılabilir oldu
Böylece bilginin değeri düştü ama bilgi
yorumlayabilme becerisi yükseldi Bu
sefer de insan Salt veriye sahip bu için
bilgi sahibi olduğunu düşünür oldu bu
yüzden de her şeyi herkesten daha çok
bildiğini düşünen insan ortaya çıktı bıo
Oysa çek asıllı Fransız yazar
milankundura anında dediği gibi
bunca gelişmeye rağmen
gündelik objelerin nasıl çalıştığını
bile bilmeyiz
Evet şimdiye kadar anlattığım Tüm bu
faktörler ahlakımızı da şekillendiriyor
ve bu ahlak yeni bir ahlak eskisiyle de
çekilişe bilen bir ahlak Bak eskiden
makamın büyüdükçe boyun küçülsün derdik
netflix döneminde başarı için her şey
mübahtır diyoruz
toplum olarak kuralların çiğ ne ne
bileceğim ve esnetilebilen eceee ne dair
ortak bir görüşümüz var o Biz diyoruz ki
kuralları ne kadar çok çiğnersek sağlam
bir kültür oluşmakta oluşturmakta o
kadar zorlanırız bu biraz da genç ve
dinamik bir toplum olmamızdan
kaynaklanıyor olsa gerek bu yüzden
değişimlere hızlı girer ama içini
doldurmakta zorlanırız
bu
işte saydığım bu tüm bu faktörler insanı
hem olumlu yönde hem de olumsuz yönde
değiştiriyor olumsuz yönde nasıl
değiştirdi diye bakacak olursak yaz daha
fazla mutsuz daha kaygılı ve güvensiz
bireyciliği miz yükseldi ve ne kanik [ __ ]
tik peki olumlu yönde nasıl değişik diye
baktığımızda
insanın anlam arayışı yükseldi artık
işimiz de anlam arıyoruz sosyal
ilişkilerimizde anlam arıyoruz aile
yaşantımızın anlamlı olmasını istiyoruz
bu
mekanik değişmeye karşı bir direnç
oluştu rutinden ritüele geçiş yapıyoruz
Örneğin dijital leşme döneminde yeniden
plakları ve pikaplara sarılmış
durumdayız
yenilik arayışımız bilindik ürünlerin
yeniden tanımlanma ihtiyacını ortaya
çıkarttı Bu
o
örenme arzumuz yükseldi artık verilen ne
yetiniyoruz daha fazla öğrenmek
istiyoruz biz her şeye rağmen
sosyalleşme beklentimiz artışı ve son
olarak kalıcılık Eskiden insanlar çocuk
sahibi olarak ya da mal mülk sahibi
olarak kalıcı olabileceğini düşünürdü
günümüzde her alanda üretken olarak
kalıcı olmayı hedefliyoruz
gördüğünüz gibi her dönemin kendine has
konuları sorunları ve kendini hasta
çözümleri var bu dönemin Bu altı kendine
has çözüm yolu bizleri hem kendimizi
tanımak için iyi bir imkân veriyor Hem
de istediğimiz toplumsal yaşama
yaratabilmek için muhteşem fırsatlar
sunuyor Bu fırsatları iyi
bu ve daha da güzel günlerde yeniden
birarada olmak gereğiyle teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]